good afternoon everyone I am Fred Harris
professor of political science and
director of the Center on
african-american politics and society
and I would like to welcome all of you
to this evenings roundtables discussion
on racial inequality in the Age of Obama
now this evenings event is sponsored by
the Center on African American politics
in society as well as the school for
International and public affairs the
Center on african-american politics and
society known as caps is an affiliate of
the Institute for Research Institute for
social and economic research and policy
here at Columbia won a caps goal is to
support theoretically sophisticated and
policy informed research using a variety
of methods and approaches that intersect
various disciplines including political
science psychology sociology law
economics and urban study this evenings
event is supported with the generous
support of the Institute for Research in
African American Studies known as iris
which also direct and the Center for the
study of ethnicity and race now to the
topic of the evening for most observers
the election of President Barack Obama
herald a new pulse raesha
racial era in which race would no longer
be significant either as a barrier to
individual success or as an object of
group antagonism Obama's ascendancy
seems to many to mark the culmination of
the long civil rights struggle for
recognition rights and equality after
all if an African American especially
one whose political identity so
carefully avoided the sharp binary
distinction of an earlier era era could
become president what barriers could
remain a year-and-a-half into Obama's
into the Obama era era the realities of
recession war and intense political
divisiveness defined the political
moment the nearly giddy ethos II azzam
of the campaign and election has
subsided and with it perhaps the hope of
a post-racial America consequently
racial inequality in the United States
poses both a policy challenge and an
analytical puzzle nearly half a century
after the peak of the civil rights
movement racial identity remains a
significant predictor of class status
and life chances across a wide range of
social and economic domains including
income wealth employment education
housing health criminal justice and
others african-americans and other
minority groups lag consistently behind
whites with severe consequences not only
for the world's well-being of
disadvantaged group members but also for
the health of American democracy now we
have three three guests one guess I hope
is on his way who's going to help us
think about the dilemma of social racial
inequality in age of Obama and I think
he's coming right through the door at
very timely Charles in blow is the
visual op-ed columnist for The New York
Times it's thought-provoking charts and
graphs and essays appear every Saturday
in The Times the stove low graduated
magna laude from Grambling State
University in Louisiana they received a
BA degree in mass communications what
caught my eye for in inviting mr. blow
here is actually an op-ed piece he wrote
on December 4th title black in the Age
of Obama mr. blow documented the high
rates of black unemployment in a column
and the consistently high levels of
black support for the president in that
piece missed the blow concluded and I'm
alone
here and the age of Obama so quietly
seems less about Obama as a black
community game-changer then as a white
house gamesman it's unclear if there
will be a positive Obama effect but in a
Obama backlash is increasingly apparent
meanwhile black people are also living a
tale of two actions grin and bear it
we'll hear more from mr. blow later in a
minute IRA Katznelson is no string of
chair to Columbia University he is
currently the Ruggles professor of
political science and history at
Columbia and one of the nation's leading
thinkers on the institutional
consequences of social and racial
inequalities in 1994 professor Katz
Nelson returned to Columbia where he has
been an assistant and an associate
professor from 1969 to 1974 in the
interim he taught at the University of
Chicago the graduate of faculty of the
New School for Social Research where he
was deemed from 1983 to 1989 is the
author of several landmark studies
including the classic black man white
cities and most recently when
affirmative action was white an untold
story of racial inequality in
twentieth-century America William Julius
Wilson his university professor at
Harvard University and the director of
the joblessness and urban poverty
research program at the Kennedy School
of Government is the nation's leading
perhaps I would argue one of the world's
leading experts on urban poverty and
racial and ethnic inequality before
joining Harvard's faculty in 1996
professor Wilson served on the faculty
of the university cago for 24 years and
founded and directed the center forced
the study of urban inequality among his
landmark books are the declining
significance of race and the truly
disadvantaged most recently he is the
author of more than just race being
black and poor in the inner city lastly
our moderator for the evening is my
colleague Robert C Lieberman professor
Lieberman is professor political science
and public affairs and vice dean for
dynamic Affairs at school for
international and public affairs here at
Columbia is the author of shifting the
color line race and the American welfare
state in shaping race policy the United
States in comparative perspective now
with all of those introductions we get
to the meat of the matter professor
Lieberman Thank You Fred and thank you
all for coming I'm just gonna offer a
couple more introductory remarks before
we turn things over to the panelists in
addition to the policy challenge that
Fred outlined racial inequality in the
post-civil rights era poses a severe
analytical challenge for students and
observers of American politics and
society in the wake of the Civil Rights
revolution of the 1950s and 60s
the most obvious barrier sir racial
equality in racial equality
state-sponsored and sanctioned
segregation explicit discrimination and
widespread racism among the white public
have declined dramatically as factors in
American life
moreover the anti-discrimination regime
created by the civil rights laws of the
1960s especially the civil rights and
voting rights acts has been
comparatively successful at rooting out
the most egregious practices of racial
exclusion and institutionalizing racial
racial integration as a widespread
public policy goal but these changes
while they have dramatically improved
life chances for many members of racial
and ethnic minority groups have not
closed the gap entirely and multiple
sources of inequality residency
education employment income well among
many others still overlap and reinforce
one another moreover as labor market and
income inequality have increased and
hardened in recent decades the racial
gap has become more acute not less in
many respects this general puzzle the
the stickiness of race the persistence
of racial inequality in what many want
to term a post-racial world is both a
profound challenge for American politics
and a fundamental question for scholars
and other observers of America
Society we hope that the discussion
tonight will address two overlapping but
related sets of questions
the first which Fred largely sketched
out is largely empirical what is racial
inequality in America looked like today
how similar or different is it to the
patterns that we observed twenty or
fifty or a hundred years ago in what
domains has American society made most
progress in recent decades and where
have we fallen most short is the
post-racial Society insight or is it an
illusion a mirage a friendly image that
we like to console ourselves with but
one that that still has we haven't
achieved the second set of quest to an
overcome racial inequality in
contemporary America it's essential that
we have a clear picture of what the
problem is and where the most pressing
challenges lie but equally if not more
urgent is to understand how and why
racial inequality persists in the Obama
era without this kind of understanding
progress I think will be impossible if
not very difficult to achieve and
therefore tonight's second set of
questions is primarily explanatory
analytical how can we account for the
stubborn persistence of racial
inequality despite the decline of the
factors that apparently accounted for it
in the past how do we expose model and
test what you might call the
subterranean effects of race in
contemporary American society given our
answers to these questions what are the
most promising political and policy
strategies that we might reach for that
that we might hope that governments will
adopt to address these kinds of
challenges all of our panelists have
made thoughtful and important
contributions to this urgent inquiry
William Julius Wilson as Fred said and
most recently in his book I have
show-and-tell more than just race being
black and poor in the inner city has
shown how social economic and cultural
fork to forces have interacted over the
decades to perpetuate and in many ways
to deepen black poverty and racial
inequality of particularly in American
cities IRA Katznelson in an equal and
also in a lifetime of work most recently
in when affirmative action was white mob
has shown how public policies politics
institutions and region have interacted
since the New Deal to construct and
perpetuate racial inequalities and
Charles blow regularly and penetratingly
shows and I mean that quite literally in
stunning graphics that he publishes
weekly and the times how what
contemporary inequality looks like and
and we're very very pleased that they've
all agreed to join us tonight and share
some thoughts what we've done is we've
asked each of the panelists to begin
with ten or fifteen minutes of opening
remarks after which we will open it up
for discussion among the panelists and
we hope some questions from the audience
and we'll begin without thanks thank you
very much the Dean of african-american
historians John Hope Franklin was born
on January 2nd
1915 1915 was the Year Woodrow Wilson
gathered his cabinet to watch DW
Griffith's racist filmed The Birth of a
Nation a film that celebrated the Ku
Klux Klan for bringing order to the
American South after the disasters in
the film's view produced by emancipation
and especially reconstruction the
president that as President Wilson is
reported to have said and we're not
absolutely sure he said this but he's
widely reported to have said as the
lights came up quote it is like writing
history with lightning and my
only regret is that as it is all so
terribly true seven years earlier
president William Howard Taft at his
inaugural in the most excruciating ly
boring inaugural address of the 20th
century um had a middle set of
paragraphs devoted to a powerful
statement which I neglected to bring
with me so I'm only paraphrasing in
which he announced as a Republican
leader of the party of Lincoln that the
federal government no longer had any
more concern with events in the American
South with respect to race the south he
said had met the tests of the 14th and
15th amendments to the Constitution
through the Jim Crow constitutions that
had been adopted starting with
Mississippi in 1890 and moving through
the year nineteen eight when he was
elected president of the United States
John Hope Franklin died on March 9th
2009 seven weeks after the inauguration
of Barack Hussein Obama shortly before
his death President Franklin a sorry
president would that it have been
president Franklin professor Franklin
whom I was privileged to know as a
colleague at the University of Chicago
and as a neighbor on Blackstone Avenue
in Hyde Park lived right down the street
had this to say about the emergence of a
black president and I quote I was
thinking that this is one of the most
historic moments if not the most
historic moment in the history of our
country it is amazing remarkable an
indication of willingness as well as the
ability of this country to turn a
significant corner toward full political
equality and he told of a game he had
played as a child with his mother she
had counseled him that when anyone asked
him what do you want to be when you grow
up he should reply I want to be the
first Negro president of the United
States of America
just those words John Hope recalled were
so far-fetched so incredible that we
would have fun just saying them who
indeed might have anticipated a
president however moderate and centrist
whose professed heroes include not just
Martin Luther King but Ella Baker and
Fannie Lou Hamer Bob Moses and John
Lewis anyone who denies the radical
transformations that have taken place
during the nine and a half decades of
John Hope Franklin s life would be deaf
and blind but equally any claim that we
live in a post-racial America is
unpersuasive and incoherent north and
west as well as south race remains the
most profound marker of difference and
the most powerful source and indicator
of deep inequality notwithstanding
massive changes that have transformed
the broader composition of the country
during the past half-century making it
less white and more demographically
complex the black/white divide the one
that has defined the core fault line of
the United States since the founding
remains fundamental but racial
inequality has changed of course in a
good many respects America has become
more fair and just with openings in the
central institutions of the country to
block participation like this University
and with the closing of various income
gaps especially between well-educated
women but since the landmark Brown
decision and the revolutionary civil
rights legislation of the 1960s America
simultaneously has become more not less
segregated the idea of a black nation
within the larger nation has become more
real more of a stubborn fact for
millions of African Americans who live
almost wholly separate lives from white
Latino
asian-americans we can see the
separation and housing and schooling in
vast remaining inequalities of income
and especially in wealth and in various
weary engagements at the junction of
white and black now no one has done more
to probe this duality than William
Julius Wilson so I look forward keenly
to his remarks about where in his view
things now stand my own remarks this
evening are more somewhat abstract I
should like to define or at least
explore criteria which might help us set
goals and assess claims about racial and
post racist not post-racial but post
racist possibilities racism in America
has not been a singular thing it's been
a compound of at least the following
elements first there have been physical
barriers that is limits placed on where
persons are allowed to be physically
present literally which schools which
homes which firms even which toilets
second has been physical insecurity a
vulnerability to violent formal and
informal official and unofficial
policing to keep blacks in their place
third element of racism has been limits
to the right to earn a living
on equal terms including access to
training and jobs fourth has been a
system of cultural restriction a denial
of cultural capital a history of forced
cultural dare assassination and fifth
has been of course the denial
historically a full civic membership
including access to the main
institutional sites of political life
and to the assets distributed by the
public realm the racial situation in
America at any moment has been fashioned
by the degree to which and with respect
to whom restrictions
exist or have existed at each of these
five levels and it is the specific
situation that particular individuals
families and groups have faced who
belong to black America as well as their
relationships with whites that these
circumstances have defined that have
created the framework for race to work
itself out
as experience in daily life in how race
shapes dispositions to behave and how
race does or does not become an
exclusive or non-exclusive basis for
collective action with race understood
this way as a complex and layered
variable or factor in life the word
variables far too weak to capture the
meaning of race what would constitute
not just movement toward but the
achievement of us post racist society a
society of racial equality note again
that I refuse to say colorblind or
post-racial because neither I believe is
itself the goal that our society should
seek to find answers that is to discern
non utopian imperative empirical and
normative criteria I want very briefly
to look at look to three leading
political theorists Michael Walzer the
late John Rawls and Amy Gutmann in 1990
Walzer published an essay in The New
School Journal social research called
what does it mean to be an American his
answer in the tradition of Horace Kaelin
the new school's famous early 20th
century student of ethnicity and one of
the inventors of the idea of cultural
pluralism concerned the power and
possibilities of the hyphenated American
and let me just cite two or three
passages
from the essay by Walzer first about the
word American the in in and the
hyphenated American think of Polish
American polish on the Left American on
the right side what is the meaning of
those words in that compound phrase
Polish American word Irish American or
Jewish American the adjective American
says Walzer named
and still names a politics that is
relatively unqualified by religion or
nationality or alternatively is
qualified by so many religions and
nationalities as to be free from any one
of them
it is this freedom that makes it
possible for America's oneness to
encompass and protect its many Nestico
zhan to say that the - in the case of
the history of ethnic Americans white
ethnic Americans this - in the
hyphenated American ISM works when it is
working he says more like a plus sign
it's a plus B polish and American and
it's not simply so that there's the
ethnic designator on one side and the
American as other he goes on to say
because individual members of this
hybrid are in the example he gives of
Irish Americans are culturally Irish
American and on the other side of the -
are politically Irish and American so
you have a very complex meaning of what
it means to be an American with a basis
in particularity and a linkage to
something a universal compound called
American he then goes on to final points
about Walzer to distinguish what he
calls the core of a group
from them the periphery of the ethnic
group at a group score the left side of
the double - tends to be the stronger
along the periphery of the group the
right side is stronger think of Polish
American polish American leaders some
who live in Greenpoint in Brooklyn speak
polish in the street as well as at home
and shop in stores that have polish
signage but most other polish Americans
don't live in neighborhoods like
Greenpoint many have even changed their
names no one would know that they have
Polish heritage there's that sweep of
choice and mutual constitution of polish
nests and Americans now what is so
striking about the history of black
Americans of African Americans is
precisely the exclusion from this world
of the duality of hyphenated American in
the same sense of choice the choice of
how strong or how weak the left side
should be in relationship to the
American side for African Americans
throughout almost all of American
history arguably through all of American
history that choice simply has not
existed so the first criterion I wish to
suggest of a post racist America would
be in America in which people of color
African American people of color would
have the same status and standing with
respect to the - African American as
poles would to polish American or Jews
to Jewish American or Irish to Irish
American it's not a simple compound and
of course complicated by phenotype as
opposed to cultural background but
having said that the test test number
one it seems to me is whether or not
African Americans could join that
meaning the walls are meaning of what it
means to be an American
second I want to know
two features of the work of John Wall
Rawls very briefly in the theory of
justice his second principle the so
called difference principle famously
stipulates that inequalities are to be
permitted only when they help the least
well-off in society
Rawls did not ban unevenness in
resources a utopian goal but he demanded
that there exists a process in a just
society that tends towards equalization
this too is a political theory aiming at
choice for assets for choice and in his
late work political liberalism Rawls
also makes room for group diversity
based sometimes on incommensurable
political and cultural differences he
asks how groups can gain maximum choice
about their cultural particularity
without losing the possibility of
belonging to a common polity and his
solution as most of you know is what he
called the the mechanism of an
overlapping consensus not a single
consensus but a consensus that overall
that is drawn from overlapping disparate
and sometimes in commence herbal views
among groups in civil society that's
another vision of choice and finally Amy
Gutmann
now president of the University of
Pennsylvania a distinguished political
theorist who wrote a book some years ago
on a democratic education in which she
contrasted three options meritocracy
targeted redistribution and spending on
education based on a notion of a minimum
threshold for effective citizenship and
I'd like to argue I won't argue I'll
simply state that I would like to argue
for the threshold of criterion that is
to say for citizenship to be meaningful
there must be a threshold of assets of
capable
the kind the Marquess n writes about in
order for actors to have meaningful
choice as citizens so if you take the
Walzer hyphenated meaning of what it
means to be American Rawls's difference
principle pluses notion of an
overlapping consensus and Guttman's
understanding of threshold effects taken
together I think they give us a fairly
good set of criteria a rich set of
criteria a demanding but not utopian set
of criteria for what a post racist still
racial society would look like finally
let me just say that the empirical
barriers remain immense depending on how
one counts there's anywhere from a five
to one or a 10 to 1 wealth gap across
racial lines there are deep legacies of
the past as well as present policies and
spatial arrangements that routinely
reproduce racial inequality we can as
many have said even have the persistence
of deep racism when there are no overt
racists to seek a colorblind society is
too much but to seek a most racist
society in the walls or halls of Guttman
sense is I think the challenge for us
and it's deeply estimable as I said
before um no one has thought more about
these questions than Professor Wilson
and I will perhaps not immediately yield
the floor to him but I will yield the
floor then to citizen blow whose work I
also deeply admire and have learned a
great deal from but before I sit down I
do want to end by noting that the
presidency of Barack Obama
notwithstanding the potential that it
may have opened up to signify
achievements that do not yet truly exist
that presidency opens up more
positive possibilities to move toward a
post racist society than any other
realistic circumstance I at least can
conjure but the openings the potential
will not be realized unless there is
support and passion from within American
civil society toward that very goal of a
post racist society and from this
perspective we all have much left to do
thank you very much thank you very much
I will now turn to Charles blow I'll be
brief I think I'm the only person up
here without a book so I mean I'm a
statistics guy so I look for trends in
numbers and so I'm gonna give you a
couple of sets of statistics and
hopefully they'll be a jump start for
conversation later when we have a
question-and-answer in our panel
discussion first I want to talk about
the disparity between the facts on the
ground and how African Americans are
responding to polling questions when ass
facts on the ground don't look good at
all
so the recession has hit black people
incredibly hard they were the most
likely to get the worst kinds of loans
and therefore the most likely to go into
foreclosure unemployment rates among
black people are astronomical in some
cases depending on how you slice the
category whether or not you separate out
black men or black women it could be two
or three times the unemployment rate for
whites the Department of Agriculture
published a study earlier this week
because at the end of last year about
food insecurity which is the fancy word
they use now for people who are hungry
because hunger is a dangerous word
using the political environment black
kids were the most likely to suffer from
food insecurity also there are you know
real things happening on the ground
the F the FBI tracks hate crimes hate
crimes against every other race or group
of people have declined in the last year
they if you put them all together daily
crime by 11 percent for African
Americans they increased by 4% if you
look at the two years that Barack Obama
has been on the scene as a candidate and
now racial hate crimes against other
groups of people fell by 19% and rose by
8% among blacks so a lot is happening
during his administration over the time
not it is just a strange confluence of
events maybe or maybe there's some
cause-and-effect relationship to these
things that's the question now look at
the way that blacks answer polling
questions there is a certain rallying
effect around Barack Obama if you put
Rock Obama's name in a question and you
ask it people say yes we have you know
blacks are now twice as many blacks now
as in 2007 say that the situation of
black people in this country is better
than it has been in five years a
majority of blacks say that life for
blacks in the future will be better than
it is now
I mean you dis allistic the Pew Research
Institute put out this study in January
so 119 pages and pretty much on every
measure black said yes they want the
most telling about how it doesn't
reflect reality was a question at least
for me it was a question that they've
been asking for a very long time which
is how do you see the account of the US
economy excellent or how many of you see
it as excellent good in 2007 2008 it was
around
an 8% Barack Obama's elected he doubles
at the same time black unemployment
doubles happy to be if his know there's
there's a certain s I mean somebody
quoted the piece where there's a grin
and Barrett mentality people are very
reluctant to be critical of him and of
the government
black people are as long as he is in
power because it they there's a certain
kind of pride in his presidency that is
widely shared and so there is not a lot
of fuss there was you know some black
leaders have been putting up a fuss they
say you know Rocco bomber should have a
black agenda separate from all the other
agendas this group has been hit harder
than any other in many ways and he
should have a separate gym for that
Barack Obama was not gonna touch that
with a ten-foot pole they keep telling
him do it he won't do it he won't say it
he won't you know that's just not he
knows that politically is radioactive
now I should they ask I think yes I
think you know there are a lot of groups
who have specific agendas the the gay
community has specific agenda they've
made a lot of noise and they get paid
attention to that said even though he's
not saying anything I think there's a
bit of a stealth agenda there a lot of
the things that he's tackling
disproportionately help the
african-american community so you have
health care
well that's disproportionately black and
Hispanics who are going to benefit from
health care reform you have the race to
the top in education will
disproportionately help black young
black and Hispanics you have even
Michelle Obama's focus on childhood
obesity will disproportionately help
black and Hispanics he may not be doing
it overtly and sangmi he's doing it I
wanna place a $10 bet on the fact
he's doing it without discussing it so
that's that's one side of it
the other side is something moves
brought up before which is the idea of
progress yes now we don't have laws that
say where you can live and what you can
do and separating people by race in a
lot of ways economically things have
gotten a lot better the problem is
whatever progress is made that last ten
yards before you get across into
touchdown zone are the stubborn nasty
ten yards it is the area where you have
racism without racist right
you have people don't even know that
they are being racist there's a there's
a great test online if you want to take
this is called the Harvard implicit
racist intensive what is actual name of
it and what they found is that every
group of people has an implicit racial
bias for whites and against blacks
except blacks who have no who don't seem
to show any preference they're kind of
equal preferences for both blacks and
whites and this is even among people
that that I talked to the Brian knows
like the guy who is in charge of it he
says you know people come out of it
really angry because a lot of people who
have who think they're the most
egalitarian people on the planet they
have they've done all this work they've
you know they they they go out of their
way you know at least they think to to
make the world a better place
even they come out showing an implicit
bias towards for whites
Plus and how does this play cell phone
all throughout society so you have
doctors who do not prescribe the same
treatments for blacks and whites they
don't even know they're doing it until
somebody looks at the data in aggregate
way and says okay this is if you look at
all the data you you're imbalanced you
have judges if you have black man black
man at the same crime the black guy is
more likely to get sentenced to prison
time that is all judges even black
judges are more likely to send us black
people to prison time then white people
it plays itself out all across society
and nobody knows they're doing it so you
look at you know take this is one last
example
so The Times had a story the other day
blacks more likely blacks and Latinos
New York City ten times more likely to
be stopped and frisked good whites so
the way this works a lot of a lot of
reason they're being stopped and when
the arrests actually happened is for
low-level drug crimes right this is like
a marijuana a little somebody ever join
in their pocket whatever so the way they
do it is they have it as a program so
we're putting cops into historically
high crime neighborhoods well we know
where that is so you have this flood of
young cops into black Hispanic
neighborhoods they're there to cut their
teeth so partner cutting your teeth as
you do these low-level stop and frisk
it's not really you know you're not you
know looking up for murderers and
whatever just stopping kids on the
street see him talking to them see if
they have something on them so what
happens they say you have you have
anything in your pocket you might want
to tell us now if you don't you're gonna
be in trouble well having smaller mas
marijuana it's not a crime showing it is
a crime
so the kiddies was 1719 years so it
pulls it out okay all of a sudden now
you going to jail look at the cob does
it at the end of his shift over time you
get overtime maybe your boss is right
dig it looks good for the number she
you're you're arresting all these people
it looks like you're doing your job if
you know if you're making arrests we
know where you are if you're just riding
around apart we don't know what you're
doing you might be the donut shop we
don't know what you do so we know you're
doing something so the city looks good
the cob looked good his boss looks good
and everybody got a little extra money
in their pocket for doing it right so
how does this relate to Obama or or to
the Age of Obama well here's the problem
for the low-level drug offenses this
thing called burn grants federal is it's
named after a guy police officer in the
city they basically pay them for these
did you get grants for how many a
low-level drug arrests remaining so
basically the city's getting money from
the government to keep doing the
stimulus package tripled the amount of
money available for Berggren so now
there is a giant pot of money sign by
Obama is a giant pot of money now to put
more people into these neighborhoods so
the cop is not necessarily racist this
is his job he just got out of you know
the Academy they placed him in bed-stuy
they told to go and look for people
behave that you know what they called
visiting or whatever they call them when
you make some jerky movement they look
for the guy making the jerky movement
which is anybody not at the cops or
arresting all of us out jerky - every
time I see
they everybody jerks everybody gets tops
they tell them all to take out the joint
they all go to jail and everybody makes
money off of it and there's no one in
that system
who's necessarily the racer and that's
all I have thank you you know I agree
with Professor Lee Berman's opening
remarks that this general puzzle the
persistence of racial inequality in a
so-called post-racial world who is both
a profound challenge for American
politics and a fundamental question for
scholars of American society now as we
reflect on this statement we need to be
reminded about the legacy of historic
racism and discrimination aside from the
enduring effects of slavery Jim Crow
segregation public school segregation
legalized discrimination residential
segregation the FHA's redlining of black
neighborhoods in the 1940s and 1950s the
construction of public housing projects
and poor black neighborhoods employer
discrimination and other racial acts and
processes there is the impact of
political economic and policy decisions
that were at least partly influenced by
race over the years in other words we
need to consider the cumulative effects
of race that remain with us today and
until we do effective
with such conditions as the
disproportionate concentration of blacks
in low-paying jobs and in the jobless
rights conditions that represent the
legacy of previous racial discrimination
segregation and racism race will
continue to be an important factor in
American society and assertions about a
post-racial Society become meaningless
especially when we when we consider all
vulnerable many of these black workers
are to current economic trends and
conditions as a late black economist
Vivian Henderson put it it's as if
racism having put blacks in their
economic place stepped aside to watch
technological changes and changes in the
economy destroy that place and he was
referring to the computer revolution
which rewards skilled workers including
skilled black workers and displaces
low-skilled workers including high
school dropouts who represent a major
problem a major social problem in the
african-american community and Henderson
was also lamenting about the the effects
of the growing internationalization of
economic activity where low-skilled
blacks and other low-skilled workers are
competing with low-skilled workers in
developing countries around the world
well skilled African Americans are
particularly vulnerable to global
economic changes for example take the
apparel industry an industry that has
been hard hit by the globalization of
the economy forty percent of all workers
in this industry are black blacks have
borne the brunt of the industrialization
as well a higher percentage of black
workers have been displaced because of
economic changes caused by the reduction
or removal of industrial capacity or
active
in Central City areas than that of any
other group of workers all of these
changes have contributed to the sharp
growth in black joblessness in recent
years but the growth of black
joblessness is seen in its most severe
form at the neighborhood level poor
inner-city neighborhoods have always
featured high levels of poverty
what has characterized them in recent
years is the impressive and precedent
high levels of joblessness back in the
1950s inner-city black neighborhoods
were poor but a substantial majority of
adults had jobs they were described as a
working poor in the same neighborhoods
today we won't often refer to the
jobless poor neighborhoods in which a
majority of adults are not working in a
typical week either because of
unemployment or because they have
dropped out of the labor force
altogether there are several reasons for
the sharp decline in employment in these
neighborhoods one is related to the
interaction of demographic and economic
changes in the latter part of the 20th
century federal transportation and
highway policies made it easier for
industries to relocate to cheaper labor
production areas in the suburbs in the
out migration of industries was
accompanied by the out migration of
higher income families
aided by mortgage interest tax
exemptions and home mortgages for
veterans the improved transportation and
suburbanization of employment
accelerated the out migration of central
city industries with industrial jobs no
longer readily available in Central City
and inner-city areas the great migration
wave of blacks from the south to
northern urban areas abruptly
ended around 1970 so with the secession
of migration from the south and the out
migration of higher income families many
poor black inner-city neighborhoods
especially those in the Midwest and
Northeast changed from densely populated
communities of recently arrived migrants
to deep populated areas with numerous
vacant lots and abandoned buildings for
example in 2005 there were 60 abandoned
buildings in Philadelphia 40,000 in
Detroit and 20,000 in Baltimore these
neighborhoods also include a much larger
proportion of poor families and
significantly higher levels of
joblessness in part due to the exodus of
higher income families who are more
likely to be employed and in part due to
the decline of industrial employment in
the inner city as well as the decline of
local businesses that depend on the
resources of higher income groups many
of whom had departed to make matters
worse for the families left behind in
these neighborhoods urban sprawl
makes it more difficult for many of them
to get to areas of employment growth
given the inadequate metropolitan
transit system commuters today depend
more on automobiles to get to employment
areas our study revealed that only 19%
of the residents in Chicago's inner city
ghetto neighborhoods have access to an
automobile this is a major problem
because they suburbs of many central
cities Derrell have developed originally
as vet veteran localities for commuters
to the central business and
manufacturing districts have become
employment centers in themselves for
example in Detroit Philadelphia and
Baltimore less than 20% of the jobs are
now located within 3 miles of the city
center in Cleveland and
Cleveland metropolitan area although
entry-level workers are concentrated in
the inner-city neighborhoods 80% of the
entry-level jobs are in the suburbs more
with a breakdown of the informal job
network system which is associated with
the sharp rise in joblessness makes it
difficult for inner-city residents to
get information about suburban job
opportunities through the informal job
network including job referrals
now given the high rate of joblessness
and diminishing job prospects in these
poor black neighborhoods I get impatient
when people start talking about a
post-racial Society jobless
neighborhoods creates special problems
that exacerbate conditions reinforcing
racial stereotypes and prejudices high
rates of joblessness trigger other
problems in the neighborhood ranging
from crime gang violence and drug
trafficking to family breakups in the
organization of family life take drug
trafficking drug trafficking as many
studies have revealed the decline in
legitimate employment opportunities
among inner city residents has increased
incentives to sell drugs and
neighborhoods plagued by higher levels
of joblessness and sufficient economic
opportunities and high residential
mobility are unable to control the
volatile drug market and the violent
crimes related to it as a result the
behavior and norms in the drug market
are more likely to influence the action
of others in the neighborhood even those
who are not directly involved in drug
activity drug dealers escalate the use
and spread of guns in the neighborhood
which in turn raises the likelihood that
others particularly youngsters will come
to view the possession of weapons as
necessary or desirable
self-protection settling disputes
gaining respect from peers and other
individuals indeed one of the reasons I
strongly urged my students to watch
HBO's the war was because David Simon
the creator of this critically acclaimed
TV series brilliantly captured what I'm
talking about
moreover as a criminologist Alfred Blum
Stein pointed out and as was depicted so
clearly in HBO's noir the drug industry
actively recruits teenagers in the
neighbourhood partly because they will
work more cheaply and partly because
they tend to take risks that more mature
adults would have shoo inner-city black
use with limited prospects for stable
and an attractive employment or easily
lured into drug trafficking and
therefore easily find themselves
involved in the violent behavior that
accompanies it
many of these youngsters are high school
dropouts as my Harvard colleague Bruce
Western revealed and his important book
punishment and inequality in America
following the collapse of the
low-skilled urban labor markets and the
creation of jobless ghettos in our
nation's inner cities incarceration grew
among those with the highest jobless
rates indeed a significant proportion of
black males who have been in prison or
high school dropouts as Western points
out among black male high school
dropouts the risk of imprisonment has
increased to 60 percent establishing
incarceration as a normal stopping point
on the route to midlife to repeat until
we deal effectively with such problems
race will continue to be an important
factor in American society and
assertions of
a post-racial society become meaningless
now let me conclude my remarks with some
brief comments and why the notion of a
post-racial society does not apply even
when we focus on the changing status of
more privileged blacks in particular
trained and educated blacks in a 1978
paper presented at an N double ACP
conference in New York quipped and the
Whorton then then Chancellor of the
State University of New York stated
quote and speaking in 1978 quote in 1966
45% of all black college graduates were
majoring in education today only 26% are
in 1966 only 5% of the blacks were
studying business today 18% are unquote
now this is one of the reasons why the
incomes of younger black college
graduates were so much higher than the
incomes of older black college graduates
who tended to be concentrated and lower
paying fields such as teaching Social
Welfare and segregated services older
black college graduates were rarely
employed as executives or professionals
and large corporations when they entered
the labor market this is not true of
younger black college graduates indeed
one study published several years ago
revealed that the incomes of blacks who
graduated from college in 1981 matched
the income of their white counterparts
even more spectacular state the author's
quote black college graduates obtained
more prestigious posts than their white
counterparts unquote but the authors of
this study warned that the racial parity
achieved by young black
by young college-educated blacks in the
1970s will be maintained only if the
government's commitment to affirmative
action does not slacken unquote a later
study suggests that these concerns were
justified analyzing longitudinal data
from the panel study of income dynamics
that captured the period when Ronald
Reagan was president of the United
States the authors of this study argued
quote that the government's retreat from
anti-discrimination initiatives in the
1980s resulted in organizational
discrimination against Blacks and
contributed to the reversal in the
post-war trend toward racial parity in
earnings unquote and I have done some
further analysis of current population
reports microdata and I found that
despite some improvements during the
1990s by 2007 the income ratio of young
black and white college graduates was
significantly below I repeat
significantly below the ratio of 1977
the research suggests that the white
backlash against racial entitlements
such as affirmative action contributed
to the government's retreat from
anti-discrimination policies during the
1980s a retreat that may have influenced
hiring and promotion decisions in the
corporate sector as well it should not
be surprising that waning support for
affirmative action programs would have
an adverse effect on blacks especially
more advantaged blacks a number of
empirical studies have revealed
significant differences in the family
environment and neighborhood environment
of blacks and whites that are
understated when standard measures of
socioeconomic status are employed take
for example the question of family
background people and white parents and
black parents report the same average
income white parents have substantially
more assets than do black parents
whites with the same amount of schooling
it's blacks usually attend better high
schools and colleges furthermore
children's test scores are affected not
only by the social and economic status
of their parents but also by the social
and economic status of their
grandparents this means that it could
take several generations before
adjustments and social economic
inequality produced their full benefits
thus if we were to rely solely on the
standard criteria for college admission
like SAT scores even many children from
black middle income families would be
denied admission in favor of middle
income whites who are not weighed down
by the accumulation of disadvantages
that stem from racial restrictions and
therefore who therefore tend to score
higher on these conventional tests for
all these reasons the success of younger
educated blacks remains heavily
dependent on affirmative action programs
whereby more flexible criteria of
evaluation is used to gauge potential to
succeed the policy implications are
obvious race specific policies like
affirmative action will be required for
the foreseeable future to ensure the
continued mobility of educated blacks
but affirmative action programs are not
really designed to address the problems
of poor blacks which require greater
emphasis on demand-side solutions such
as creating tight labor markets whereby
employers are looking for workers rather
than rather than workers looking for
employers the point is that a continuous
struggle is needed to address the
problems of racial inequality some
calling for race-based solutions like
affirmative action others calling for
class-based solutions such as programs
to increase employment and areas with
the highest rates of joblessness for all
of these reasons even though we have
made significant progress
it is indeed premature
to talk seriously about a post-racial
society
thank you thank you very much bill well
we've had three compelling sets of
remarks and we have about 20 or 25
minutes left for questions so if you
would like to ask a question there's a
mic standing in the middle of the floor
so I asked you to make your way way make
your way to the mic or not
and if you could identify yourself as
you're asking the question I'm Aubrey
Hendricks I'm visiting Scotland
Department of religion african-american
studies here Columbia just a quick
question you're the conclusions to that
you share with us on education study on
education could you just share where
those those conclusions are published
the conclusions you shared in the last
part of your remarks on affirmative
action and education could you share
please where those conclusions are
published where they can they will be
published the University of Chicago
Press is breaking out a new edition of
both the truly disadvantaged and the
declining significance of race the
declining significance of worries of
race was published in 1978 with a second
edition in 1980 now people have read the
book understand it's a very pessimistic
book it's not an optimistic book you
know I recall if I just make this point
very quickly is that when Reagan became
president I got a call from the White
House said Professor Wilson we're
inviting you along with other group of
black conservatives who come to you no
and I said where did you get the idea
that I'm a black conservative they said
well you're on the list I said take me
off that
why arguing that book was a economic
class had become more important than
race and determining black life chances
that's what I meant about the declines
declining significance of race so what I
have two research assistants who were
reviewing research articles so I could
respond to these articles and and and
not only talk about the extent to which
the studies reinforce my earlier
arguments but also studies are
challenged by pieces and studies that
led me to revise my thesis and so I've
written the first draft of that of that
article which will come out which will
be published in Delos Daedalus magazine
and the Nalanda large larger version
will be published as a post grip for the
declining significance of race please
please dr. Getz Nelson as well thank you
thank you very much dr. Wilson you
mentioned John Rawls and do you see a
way that John Rawls can be used to a
greater extent other than justice
overlapping consensus in this this move
to move to go to a post-racial post
racist moment in America my remarks
which I I offered with a you know with
firm sentences with declarative
sentences with periods in my own mind
have more question marks than anything
else that that I don't like as my
colleagues on the panel don't like the
notion of a simple notion of a
post-racial Society it does violence to
reality it also does violence
potentially to the even in the best of
cases to a kind of cultural and human
plurality which would value aspects of
racial heterogeneity
but post racist seems to me to be the
right goal and what I what I set out to
do
but was to try to think of which
features of recent work recent
scholarship by some of our leading
political theorists thinking about a
decent society which would bear on and
set standards for analytical and
normative standards for thinking about
what post racism would mean beyond just
saying a reversal of racism and we've
had a lot of confusion in our society
including in some of the Supreme Court
decisions that Bill Wilson referred to
in which notions of colorblind are
associated as if they are the policy
instrument to achieve a policy value
seems to me that that language itself is
so profoundly misleading as to produce
perverse at best perverse outcomes even
if they're not intended as outcomes and
hence the look at roles if I a lot of a
tiny footnote in 1980 I was a chairman
of the political science department at
the University of Chicago and the phone
rang one day and someone said this
professor Katznelson I said yes he said
this is the office of the
president-elect
I said president-elect of what I said
the United States and the other end they
said well we've just been talking to our
friend Milton Milton Friedman and
talking to George who was George Shultz
and we thought we would check in with
our friends in the political science
department to see what help you could
give us and the assumption was basically
broadly that enveloped the US that that
the University of Chicago itself was the
simple center of conservative politics
never mind
I'll just I'll just point out that
neither colleague Wilson nor colleague
has Nelson is still at the University of
Chicago
rescue them from whatever it is that
yeah
can you Claude Steele and you you you
guys have been very persuasive about the
fact that that we are still in we are
not in a post-racial world but I'm
wondering what you think the the
reputation of being in a social in a
post-racial world the sort of Obama era
the reputation of the Obama era people's
feelings about the Obama era has done to
the capacity to mobilize to address
these inequalities I mean have you have
you noticed a change in the in the
energies and the ability to enlist
people's commitment to to working on
these things as a result in this post
Obama era well you can you can start I
have to do the statistics mail and see
party you know I think that what you're
seeing is is the opposite effect I think
that the Tea Party has arisen out of a a
kind of desperate attempt to hold on to
some semblance of what what many white
Americans believe is their birthright in
America and a lot of that is privilege
and that Barack Obama's election heralds
a future that they thought may have been
many decades off that in addition to the
changing demographics in terms of
Hispanic explosion of Hispanics in this
country there's one in every four
children born in America now is Hispanic
if you look at the estimates of the
Hispanic population it's just expected
to balloon and even if you did and not
what I did
what I did was I went back and looked at
their previous estimates and all the
previous estimates were way off they
were so low so we we don't even know if
the S
of the boom that they now predict will
even be right it may be twice what they
suspect it will be so what I see is a
kind of recalcitrance and the Tea Party
represents that in my mind very well I
mean it they if you you just have to
scratch the surface there and you get a
lot of very nasty very kind of backward
thinking about all kinds of Tolerance
including racial tolerance but also kind
of you know moral judgments across the
spectrum I did an analysis of white
voters whites and they weren't
necessarily voters there just wasn't a
population and I looked at tea people
who said they supported the Tea Party as
opposed to whites who a Republican
whites who were independents and whites
who were Democrats and on every question
of tolerance of any sort whether it is a
gray ssin questions or just kind of
conservative thought with things like
you know should wouldn't be allowed to
get abortions whatever there are way to
the extreme that said though it kind of
just surfaces something that is already
there there's a University of Washington
the University of Washington watching
universally poll last month or so when
we just last month and what they found
was that Tea Party views on the kind of
discriminatory questions are the the
questions about racial stereotypes of
black people were not very different at
all from other White's views so it kind
of surfaces something that is there it
gives voice to it they have a bunch of
big meetings and they have you know some
really bad spellers with a lot of signs
but but they basically just surface a
feeling that is pervasive
among whites in America blacks are lazy
they are more prone to violent very
pointed questions and the different the
outcomes were not very different between
them and on those measures than men
whites in general I agree with that you
know when I hear this these Tea Party
people talking about taking back America
what it means you know what it means
that aren't elaborate on that and I was
one time I was driving to my high school
graduation reunion in Pennsylvania and I
was listening to the radio and I just
turned there was there was there was
Rush Limbaugh I can't listen to the man
but he was talking about something then
that I had to listen to he was saying
that the health care bill really
represents reparations for black people
okay now it's interesting that black
leaders astutely you know recognized and
they recognize that blacks would benefit
disproportionately from health care
legislation that Latinos would benefit
legislation but they did not discuss
this publicly they would talk about it
with blacks in closed meetings in close
commuting meeting community meetings but
very few I can't think of any major
black leader fully aware of the benefits
of health care legislation for blacks I
can't think of anyone who discussed this
publicly and they recognized that the
right wing would use this to help defeat
this information to help defeat the
health care bill so they didn't say
anything about it and the point I want
to make is this it may be true that it's
becoming more difficult to a
dressed some of these issues because
obama is president but despite this
despite the fact that he was saddled
with a twenty trillion dollar debt and
an annual deficit of almost a trillion
dollars when he took office despite this
he was able to pass a health care bill
and a stimulus package that includes
sixty billion dollars for poor people
anyone had told that would just say this
what's his name Robert Greenstein of the
Center on Budget and Policy Priorities
was asked by the Obama administration
when they were when they were working up
legislation for the health care bill to
develop a budget that would address the
issues of poor people and jobless people
that could be included in the stimulus
package and so he did and he came up
with sixty billion dollars and he
apologized to the administration as I
know this is too much you know but I
just decided to put everything down and
then you can take out what what what you
really think should be deleted they said
not to worry we'll include it all he
said bill I've never seen anything like
this I mean this guy the Center on
Budget and Policy Priorities a liberal
think tank in Washington DC when they
speak people listen he says I've never
I've never experienced an administration
that was this committed to dealing with
the problems of poor people you know and
so here you have Tavis Smiley and Cornel
West and all these other people saying
that Obama should focus specifically on
race issues like coming up with a
special package for black joblessness I
mean how's a man gonna do that you know
I never thought I would find myself in
full agreement with Al Sharpton
you know and you know but Sharpton was
aware that he cannot do this right now
you know it reminds me when I was
lecturing during the time that Barack
Obama was running for president and I
was in a taxi going from the airport to
a Notre Dame where I was delivering a
lecture and there's a black cab driver
there he was very upset with an
editorial he read by Jesse Jackson in
the sun-times criticizing Obama for not
focusing more on race specific issues
and he says what is wrong with Jesse
Jackson some of these other black
leaders says how is this man gonna get
elected in this white society by talking
about these issues let the man get
elected then we could put pressure on
him but you know when I sit in my barber
shop right now and I listen to folks
you're right they don't want to
criticize Obama and they are concern
that Obama is not going to be successful
and they don't want to put pressure on
him at this point you know they want him
to survive it's very very interesting
you know you referred to this Pew
Research poll when asked blacks is Obama
doing enough for black people 83% said
yes only 13% said he wasn't doing enough
you know it's very interesting I'm sorry
I got off on all that the point I make
I'm making is that he's made a lot of
progress in introducing programs that
benefit blacks even though people don't
recognize it my name is Gwen Dubrow and
I have to disagree with you respectfully
disagree with you I'm very disappointed
in Barack Obama it's I mean it's just
there's so many things that I could I
could point to yes the stimulus package
is is okay I mean I guess it's okay but
it hasn't trickled down to where it
needs to be you know like you some in
New York there's 51 percent black men
you know black male on
you know like you said stop and Chris I
mean it's you know all that money is
going towards you know the police I mean
it's it charter schools that's gonna
that's gonna bring that's gonna destroy
public education not that it's the best
but at least you know you have your
unions and least you know you have some
sort of structure there I mean we all
saw the pictures of that that woman
beating that child and that woman I mean
as far as I know she's still roaming
free had that been the reverse and that
was oh she was beating a white child I'm
sure that woman would have been arrested
no never mind
obviously her losing her job but I don't
want to you know argue with you about
the particulars about the stimulus
package and all it is so quote good that
Obama is doing but I'm wondering why
every time he gets in front of a black
audience he's always chastising us and
never saying anything about what white
people are doing against us that's what
I'd like to know if anybody going what
do what do you expect poor black people
to do I mean other than you know
complain amongst ourselves I mean that's
not gonna get us anywhere
you know I'm personally glad that I
didn't vote for him I mean you know I
can't respond to all of that but I'll
try to
I'll just take one aspect to illustrate
the points I'm trying to make so you're
critical of Obama because he and Arne
Duncan are using the stimulus money they
have to encourage States not to cap the
creation of charter schools well you see
you right oh wait a minute you said you
say hasn't you know what studies are
really referring to let me just tell you
something let me tell you something what
Barack Obama and Arne Duncan are
concerned about is creating the kind of
competition that's going to lead to
improve conditions for kids in these
schools and they are focusing on schools
that are successful seeing if they can
be a model for other schools and one of
the the studies that they rely on are
the most rigorous studies available for
charter schools talking about the study
of charter schools in New York and a
study of charter schools in Boston and
what is interesting about these charter
schools is that they are overwhelmingly
black for example in New York City only
4% of the students in these charter
schools are white okay and both Boston
and Chicago used a gold standard random
assignment design where these kids were
selected by the lottery so you could
compare the lottery winners with a
lottery losers and so on the results are
spectacular here you have kids from some
of the most impoverished backgrounds
with scores on the statewide math and
English tests that match those of kids
an upper-middle-class white suburbia the
same thing is true with a
with the public charter schools in the
Harlem Children's Zone now why is it
that these charter schools tend to be
more successful
one reason is a longer school day that's
one thing you have in common
another reason is a ridiculously short
summer vacation you know what happens to
these kids during this summer black
intercity kids go home and watch TV
because their parents can't afford to
send them to enrichment programs and
summer camps they're there for the gap
between the haves and have-nots widens
dramatically during this summer these
charter schools aware of that and so
they reduced the summer vacation they
increase the amount of time these kids
are in school they don't have
constraints on the selection of teachers
it's not based on seniority it's based
on what you can't accomplish now I have
been sick and tired of seeing kids bake
miss educated and public schools in
America
and I think it's about time that we
tried to take a different approach at
least create a system that would
encourage the kind of competition that
we need to address these problems and
that's another thing that I give Brock
Obama and Arne Duncan credit for that is
trying to improve the education of black
kids okay well just we have I'm sorry I
wanted to say one thing I you know I
will agree with you on one point which
is I think that we have to make space
for dissent in the black community I
think that it is the the reflex that I'm
seeing in the polls is to not say
anything I think that is very dangerous
I understand why people don't want us to
talk about it I understand that that you
know people are trying to insulate him
from more criticism than he would have
for instance at the end of his first
term his approval rating among whites
was the lowest of any president ever his
who rate is hovering around 50% the only
reason that Braco they haven't written
Barack Obama's obituary
is because black people still support
him at a rate of 90 to 95% in every poll
so it can also Hispanic people support
him big-time
yeah I don't think it is but if you look
at all of all people of color it is for
hire but it is black people at that 90
percent inch approval rating that's
keeping him afloat because otherwise
he'd be down in the 30s and everybody'd
be saying he's a one-term right he's
done so I do think that you know the
people should have a space to say and I
feel like we're caught between a rock
and a hard place
a space to say there are things that I
would like to see and part of Obama's
problem in general has been
communication you know absalom
communications failure so not selling
the the healthcare packaged in the right
way it's a great thing but not sold
properly not selling the stimulus fact
people still don't think the stimulus
package is work people have jobs that
are that are financed by the stimulus
package and so he had installed things
and what and what's happening with this
stealth approach to the african-american
community is that there are a lot of
people to think just do believe just
like you that I don't see it here and I
haven't heard you say every night there
are a lot of people out there I think
who who feel like they haven't seen the
manifestations of it and because black
leaders like you were speaking before
don't even say out of their mouth that
that healthcare is going to dis
reversing lis help you people don't
think of it as a thing that this portion
disproportionately happens white people
so I think there's a communications
lapse and on that point I will agree
okay we are running out of time I'm
going to collect the few last very brief
questions these two people in the aisle
and this gentleman over here on the side
if you can make your way up to the mic
so go ahead and so we'll collect these
three last questions and then let the
panelists have the final word so why
don't you go ahead and ma'am my question
is what do you all think of the
prevalence of african-american cultural
explanations to explain why there
continues to be a discrepancy or so such
a graded let me calm down
such great disparities between
african-americans and whites cultural
dysfunctionality is it the reason why
there's such a great disparity between
blacks and whites is because black
people don't know how to act and what do
we think about the prevalence of this
explanation and a supposed post pulse
rate society I was active in the workers
movement and trade union I was a postal
worker for 30 plus years and I also
write some history and my question for
everyone here is given this white
supremists system that you all have
described my questions concern class and
given this white supremists system that
you've all described do you think that
there is a class whose interests are
served by the present setup second do
you think that there's a class whose
interests are not served by the present
setup and if so what are the
implications of your assessment well for
all three of you if you would thanks and
finally my name is Frank Lewis I'm a
statistics instructor over at NYU and I
have a question based upon a report that
way I think the New York Times
highlighted a couple weeks ago that
stated that for the first time the
suburbs had a much larger share of
people of color and I I guess this
question is specifically geared towards
you dr. Wilson dr. Wilson and my
question is and lie the fact that
there's been a substantial shift of
people of color from urban centers to
outside to the suburbs okay and not just
high middle income but also the
impoverish as well how do you
get your spatial mismatch hypothesis in
that light I don't know if people aware
the spatial mismatch hypothesis I'm sure
you can elaborate on it but it basically
has to do with the mismatch of physical
labor and demand demand of labor and
supply of labor okay thanks so I think
what we'll do is we'll have the
panelists have a chance to respond to
any and all of this in the original
order so we'll start with IRA then
Charles and then Bill and then wrap up
to the first two questions first types
one sentence that any any analysis of
culture that doesn't place it in terms
of the structural realities that shape
conditions of life life's experience
people's dispositions and the the actual
real circumstances of choice that people
face in life is dreadful cultural
analysis and we're full of such cultural
analysis in our society including an
especially cultural analysis that
concerns questions of race that does not
mean that issues that have to do with
quote culture are irrelevant or
immaterial but any any any analysis that
displaces treatments of quote culture
from quote analyses of structure strike
me as analytically ludicrous and
politically dangerous with respect to
issues of class all it's just such a big
question I make one observation which
really has that more to do with our
political legacies at the late 19th and
early 20th century one set of have-nots
in our society the children of slaves
were overwhelmingly in the Republican
Party for reasons that are obvious and
the the white working-class became
overwhelmingly members of the Democratic
Party there was a period briefly in the
1930s and 40s were they joined forces
within one political umbrella it was
also a strange bedfellows coalesce
that included southern segregationist
Democrats producing very odd outcomes
today increasingly there's been a drift
especially south of the mason-dixon line
away from the Democratic Party among
white people including white
working-class and a near unanimity of
voting for Democrats amongst blacks so
the idea of how to forge a question that
affords transracial class-based
coalition's for a kind of social
democratic politics has been an issue
that has vexed the United States for
well over a century and we're a very
long way from figuring it out well I
said to two quick little points one on
the cultural analysis thing that's why
the point one last time to that pew poll
because one thing that they found that I
thought was fascinating was that this
has only happened a couple of times in
the history of their polling but blacks
now believe that the biggest problem
facing progress among blacks is the
decisions that they themselves make and
not institutionally so even though you
know academically you may want to
analyze it one way people on the street
are looking at it a different way and
differently now and the second is I just
wanted to highlight you know on the
classes and that doesn't go directly to
class but just how odd a construct the
Democratic Party is
it is you know it is a bunch of poor
people many of them black 60% of
Hispanics I think now vote Democratic
and US East Coast elite that's pretty
much it I mean black people black people
I wrote a column about this black people
on social issues are more conservative
than what they're Republicans and then
why just ways then Republicans they're
in creditors conservative and every day
every time they go to the poll they vote
against that interest because they
cannot stand to large degree
thus the racial subtext of the
Republican Party and that scares the
Republicans to death because they
worried that Hispanics will be the new
blacks if Hispanics ever start voting
the way blacks vote they're dead they
already vote in the last election it was
like two-to-one Democratic if you tip
over to that 90% level or 80% level
they're dead and you only have to look
at Texas to understand what that means
Texas is the ruby red crown jewel of the
Republican Party you don't win the
presidential election without Texas the
the problem the problem it with Texas is
that in 20 note by 2020 if the line
keeps going the way it's going now you
will have more Hispanics in Texas than
white people right that that is that
that scares them to death and so you
could get a situation where it would be
very hard for a Republican to ever be
President on running under the platforms
that they run on today okay
than on the cultural question I didn't
have time to to include the cultural
analysis in my remarks but one of the
things that I do in my book more than
just races I talk about I talk about the
effects of living and poor segregated
neighborhoods over extended periods and
one of the effects is repeated exposure
to cultural traits that emerged from or
are the products of racial exclusion
that may impede a social mobility and
one of the things that I emphasize in a
book however is that these cultural
factors are not nearly as important as
the structural factors that I talked
about that I only had time to talk about
and I couldn't agree with you more or if
you're going to talk about cultural
responses you have to include the
structural factors in fact I made a
point in my book that a social scientist
has an obligation to make sure that his
is at her structural analysis Avista if
if they are including both structure and
culture to make sure that the structural
analysis does not recede into the
background you have to put it up front
so I've made an explicit attempt to
emphasize how important structural
factors are but if you're going to have
come up with a comprehensive explanation
you have to include you have to include
both now regarding the special mismatch
when I was talking about the special
special mismatch I was talking about
groups that are left behind in
inner-city neighborhoods it is true that
black middle-class folks are moving to
white areas not in sick
Viveca numbers but in increasing numbers
gradually increasing the integration of
some of these neighborhoods so those
people are not really affected by the
spatial mismatch soap so much that as
those were moved into white areas but
many blacks middle-class folks have
moved into suburbs that are
predominantly black or black
middle-class and research suggests or
demonstrates that they are further
removed from areas of employment growth
than comparable whites and certainly if
you focus on the inner city or should
say inner suburbs some of these poor
suburbs that are often just as poor as
inner-city neighborhoods that blacks
move in moving into they may be moving
into suburbs but they're impoverished
suburbs and they are also very very far
removed from employment opportunities
well we are overtime we could go on
quite a bit longer but I want to end by
just thanking Charles blow bill Wilson
IRA Katznelson for a terrific
you